our next guest Oklahoma linebacker
Kenneth Murray joining us here on set
Kenneth welcome to the program how are
you I'm doing good doing good give me a
give me one word that best describes the
experience here in Indianapolis for you
so far fine
all of it may you good to talk football
all day so that's fun to me have you
done your medicals yet yeah how hard is
it to just sit around and wait I feel
like a lot of guys just have to sit
around and wait it's not that bad I mean
I mean I wasn't got it you know I never
was hurt too I mean I played started
every game at Oklahoma so it's kind of
easy for me yet poke me and prod me
there's nothing wrong with me right
mm-hmm
how hard is it to stay healthy at high
level football like that 6 to 241 you
know that's a that's a a brutal position
you're in collisions car crashes all the
time how did you manage to keep yourself
healthy through all of that I think it's
just you know taking the initiative and
an understanding that you have to have a
routine to be a particularly your body
arm and I know I have extensive routine
that I go through between you know
recovery sessions you know getting type
of type of rehab and communitive
recovery work on every day before after
practice and even on Sundays after game
so I'm just having that type of routine
i'ma definitely you know helps with my
recovery for my body what do you do best
play football flour on to the ball is it
just instincts and reaction know where
the ball is and get to it yeah I would
just see I think you know the speed that
I have in linebackers extremely special
I think you know just being able to to
to put that together with with just how
intelligent I am as a player um and then
you know reacting to you know what I see
after you know the snap and they never
get to the ball give me an idea of the
speed what are you gonna run the 40 in
so I'm really really fast
well last guy said fast you say really
really fast he said fast was four three
fastest fourth is that what are you go
what are you shooting 40 hoping for
number four for four three or four four
that's fast that's fast that's like Ryan
shazier linebacker right fast and we've
seen what a difference maker a guy can
be in the middle get into the ball like
that
what when did you when did that let
light go off for you that this is gonna
work for me I'm gonna be able to do this
this is this is gonna this is a skill
set that's gonna take me to the NFL
football yeah you know you know I always
just been a lover of the game you know I
played a bunch of different positions
throughout high school um and you know I
never actually played Mike which is the
position I played now inside I reckon
until I got to college and so when I
kind of got thrusted into being you know
an inside linebacker and playing Mike
I'm just truly just fell in love with
the position I think it's just I'm gonna
fits me on really really well I'm a
natural-born leader on which is you know
you know being the quarterback of the
defense you have to be and so you know
just have you know a special way with
athleticism to be able to fly around to
the ball and just you know compare that
with my leadership
um I think you know that's just
something just makes me special well it
was back at Elkins high school in
Missouri City Texas where Kenneth Murray
started to realize how good he was we
got some highlights
let's see let's see some of the best of
Kenneth Murray and there he is and here
he comes and there he goes my goodness
all right way back wait do you remember
this one you see you know exactly what
it was okay I put this dude who you're
playing in this one playing him
that's Galveston ball
that is dominance any of these guys if
we saw that you played against her with
end up to the college level with you or
just you
I play Ross Blacklock now he was my
basically defensive tackle for us so he
wanted TCU and I mean he's here right
now come on we're here about Friday
Night Lights in Texas all the time is
that is that how it really is I mean is
that big of a deal in your town growing
up no doubt I mean it's just 100% like
you know crazy type thing I mean
everybody comes out to the games
everybody I'm excited about you know the
high school football games and so it's
really a big deal in Texas give me the
craziest story that would we would hear
and say wait this can't be happening at
high school football we give me an idea
of something that just over the top that
just shows how big of a deal of this
notice kind of like 20 30 30 40 thousand
people at one game I remember I played
versus Ridge point he was kind of a
robbery game he opens for his point and
Lily the whole stadium was packed out so
it's about about 40,000 people there I
hope she get ready for the next level
right yeah because for a lot of these
kids you see the typical high school
game there's maybe 500 people there you
walk out into a college Stadium that's a
huge adjustment
it can't be that big of an adjustment at
all there but yeah who do you look up to
in the NFL who do you want to emulate I
mean I watch the tape on a bunch of
different linebackers on you know to be
pacifica to those that I watch the
mostess Bobby Wagner and Luke Kuechly
watch a lot of Ray Lewis tape too and
you know just just taking the bits and
pieces from those guys and seeing you
know what makes them successful and
trying to implement that to my game
who's the guy you want to hit the first
guy you want to hit when you're in the
NFL first guy see with the ball that's
good answer who's the guy that's gonna
cause you to be starstruck you're gonna
see him on the field you're gonna say I
can't believe I'm on the same field as
this guy probably Tom Brady you know a
lot of guys have been saying Tom Brady
and think about how are you 21
I mean you're one year old when Tom
Brady was here combine 20 years ago yeah
this is amazing you've seen him your
whole life and
and you you maybe maybe teammate with
him we don't know where he's gonna be we
don't know where you're gonna be but
yeah you may get a chance to hit him he
may be the first guy who has the ball
when you're playing yeah no well I'll
tell you what Isiah
I mean Kenneth I'm sorry it's been a
long week we've had we've had Isiah
we've had Kenneth we've had this guy
we've had that guy it's been one after
another we appreciate Kenneth Murray and
his time and we wish you all the best
the rest of the week at the Scouting
Combine and we wait to see what you do
with the next level to serve
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports